before we get into the meat of the video
i just want to give a quick kind of life
update
i arrived in dubai a couple days ago and
you probably know this by now but
there's a world championship match
happening in dubai it should be really
exciting i'm gonna be the official
photographer for the event
so i'll be one of the few people that
have access
in the playing room to take pictures of
the players
so it should be really cool
and i thought for this video it would be
a cool experiment to hit
the nepobot on chess.com it's like the
ai version of yonder pomayashi against
the play magnus app so in this video
we're gonna see them
against each other
it turned out to be a really cool game i
don't want to share any spoilers beyond
that
but i do hope you enjoy the video it's
cool content something a bit different
than what i normally do so before we get
into the video i do want to thank the
sponsor of today's video which is
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes ranging from illustration design
coding various types of software
and it's kind of your one stop shop to
learn whatever new skill you want to
improve on in your life now one class i
can recommend is on iphone photography
and how to take photos like a pro on
your phone now i get the question all
the time about different photography
tips and how to just take really
stunning photos and i think this course
is a great kind of beginner entry point
and it offers a lot of just practical
advice it shares the basic principles of
photography
how to frame capture edit your photos it
has a whole section on how to use
lightroom which is a very powerful
photography software it's why i used to
edit all my photos now i do have a
special offer for my subscribers the
first 1000 people to click the link in
the video description we'll get a one
month free trial to skillshare so you
can start learning and discovering
everything the platform has to offer
so thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring today's video
and let's get into the carlson bot
versus nepobot
so play magnus
against nevobot i'm gonna be inputting
all the moves but hopefully the game
will be
visible i'll offer some commentary
uh nepo might do some trash talking and
we're gonna start a game not against
five-year-old magnus
but against thirty-year-old magnus
when was magnus born november 30th hey
it's almost his birthday
so he's turning and magnus is turning 31
this year
or this week
wait what
unlock level
dad's not letting me play him
x4 membership
it's making me pay 349
for a monthly membership
okay i guess that's worth it for this
video
get rid of ads forever
but probably just for the next month
take my money
face id beautiful
and here we go oh man so e4
from nepo it will be interesting how
this compares to like the first game or
first few games of world championship
match
if the openings align
magnus plays alakine knight f6
i don't think we're going to see
alekhine in any of the world
championship games
okay e5
and now knight d5
d4
so far this is alekhine theory
magnus is playing
instantly
c4
knight b6
it is weird to go back and forth between
the moves but uh
okay so main line knight f3
instant knight c6 from magnus
and now pawn e6
what is this
it's some sort of like interesting
gambit
magnus takes right away
i should notice the bishop takes there's
a fork
so let's see how this will transpire
nepo is saying it's not a real game
until the blood is spilled
yeah question mark
uh yeah
blood doesn't usually spill in chess
though
okay knight c3
pawn e5
i have no idea this is still theory
pawn d5
looks like black is giving back a pawn
okay trade on
d4 takes takes takes
and now pawn e5
from magnus
now the question is is nepo gonna on
passant
does he know the rule
has he googled it hey it's on poisson
okay bishop takes e6
so
it's equal material
position's opening up a lot
i do like white's position a bit better
opening was nice bishop d3
now queen f6 makes sense
going for a queen trade
magnus trying to
steer the game into positional territory
now takes takes and like castles
wait what did i do oh there we go white
castles
knight takes c4
looks like a free pawn
but now rook e1 oh box pieces are
a little bit shaky the bishop's pinned
and it's tied down to the thing the
knight
but knight e5 blocking the file
attacking the bishop
bishop c2
seems like white was threatening f4
but king g7 very solid so magnus is now
up upon nabo going for compensation
plays f4 removing the knight from a nice
central square
light returns to c6
or maybe f5 potentially coming
f5 has come
bishop supports it from c2
so white has some initiative
interesting compensation for the pawn
and this retreats the bishop back to f7
napo plays bishop to f4
completing development of the minor
pieces
now bishop g7 what is this move
i guess black wants to connect the rooks
the bishop is so sad on on g7 though
okay napo just putting the rooks in the
center
arguably has some nice compensation for
the pawn
but magnus is now going for trades
wants to get off all the rooks
nepo says no thanks plays bishop to e4
blocking the e-file
centralizing the bishop
and now h5 seemingly random move for
magnus but it does have the point of
trading off the the really sad bishop
uh nepo plays b3
also looking like a random move
h4 wow magnus is just pushing his h pawn
freeing the h5 square for the bishop
and now knight to b5
nepo may be looking to sacrifice
on d6
oh it's kind of a cool
idea knight e5 oh the knight returns to
its nice outpost square but leaves a few
pawns hanging on the queen side
napo declines to take any of the the
free looking pawns
moves the knight back to d4
interesting
now we should keep in mind these are two
robots playing against each other so
this game could
could be long but so far all all three
results are possible could be a draw
either side could still
have some winning chances
knight e6
a knight does not look defended
and magnus just takes the knight
pawn takes back now if rook takes
there's bishop f5 so maybe king takes
wow magnus up two pawns now
bishop to g6 played
can the two bishops stir up enough
compensation
rook eg8
getting to the open g file and now g4
enticing black to give on poisson
will magnus do it
ah he does yeah opening the h file the
rooks are about to flourish
bishop takes g3
yeah i don't think the bishop hair is
enough comp for uh
the fast attack is up two pawns now
but white's still trying to fight rook
f1
hitting the pawn on f5
oh
no
did nepo really just blunder the bishop
i guess the bishop was getting trapped
wow
magnus making this look easy
nepo says wax
what will you do now what does wax mean
in russian
i didn't see rook t6 coming
but did magnus see it
oh that maybe means shock
chalk like check
i think the w is is a ch or sch
king e7 i have king f7 there's rook f5
wow maybe this was all planned out king
e7 now the knight's hanging oh but
there's bishop d4 check in the end
uh so work out five played black is
still up a piece
but white cleaning up some pawns
knight f4
what is knight f4
i have 4 is a crazy move before i play
this move look at this move
knight f4 if the bishop takes then
there's discoveries
x-ray vision on the g-file
by the 4 also prevents the bishop from
defending the rook so it attacks the
rook with the king
that's so crazy
and the knight's like just hanging like
it's two pieces can take it but i don't
think white's gonna take it
rook d1 very calm move back
and now what to do with the knight
bishop d4
oh my gosh
this is so beautiful
bishop d4 leaving the knight attack
twice
but unleashing the pin
and now if rook takes d4 there's 92 with
the triple fork
so the king moves to h1
now black has two minor pieces hanging
but just goes ahead and takes the free
bishop because now the h2 pawn is pinned
and white only has time to take one of
these things
so the rook captures a knight
and now magnus very calmly defends the
bishop of the pawn
nice outpost square
now it's white
kind of gasping for air
king is finding some safe haven on d6
this is not looking good for white but
pawn b4 okay the game still goes
white's trying to trade off the
remaining pawns
well that's gonna be hard to do
uh you can trade on c5
not gonna help so much
pawn takes back now this is a passy pawn
da i'm getting a scam call what is this
uh decline or accept
i kind of want to accept it
and then turn into like kit boga
but that's probably not the best use of
my time
decline
yo where's my app there's my app
okay rook
d1 uh
rip d1
wait rook d1 pinning the bishop
but the bishop's defended
now rook gh3
white has a clear
tender
on h2
uh d2 played
defending the pawn
still a question how is black going to
break through
king e6
madness and firm control
rookie 2 check looks like the king might
walk up
but no bishop to
e5 walking into a pin
and now rook a4
attacking the undefended pawn
but h2 is also undefended or not
sufficiently defended
madness takes it
forcing the trader rooks
we take
and now kim ji won
king d5 this is going to be a pretty
clean conversion
for black
i'm pretty sure even i could win this
but we'll see how magnus converts it
rook takes
a7 uh pawn c4 wasting no time
white's just a little bit too slow with
everything
or d7
king e4
yeah
black has two ideas here to go for mate
or go for the the pawn promotion
white has the idea of queening but it's
going to be too slow
on c3 there's no rook c7 here
so it's rook team one
going for passive defense
ponzi 2
rook f1
magnus or nepo seems awfully quiet i
don't think nepo has said anything
recently
okay rip d2 going for rook t1
a pawn's not going to cut it
rook d1
magnus age 30 this is too strong king g2
and now the queen is born
nepo says okay but what are you planning
to do with this
i think the plan is very clear
is queen digs rook
and it's made in like two or three or
maybe four
king f2
queen d2 instantly from magnus
check minor inconvenience
but checkmate is coming i think
checkmate is going to be a major
inconvenience king g1
king f3
get ready for it
it was sad apon which is too slow
queen c1 mate the most stylish mate
and there are a bunch of mates in one
but queen c1
so magnus just says checkmate
what will nepo say
nepo says
probably some
i don't know if i want to guess what
that is in russian
he says something something
i did not expect this
play again question mark
ah it's not translating
ah my screen recording got messed up
so anyway i hope people enjoy that uh
if you have comments or feedback or want
to see
other content like this let me know in
the comments
and stay tuned for more content from
dubai and i'll see you soon